c'est devenu un rituel dès qu'ils
passent par la gare de versailles
chantiers maurice ne peut s'empêcher de
s'arrêter pour feuilleter les ouvrages
déposé dans la nouvelle boîte à livres
installés près des quais j'aime beaucoup
les romans gel et romancier japonais et
la dernière fois que je suis passé
c'était ya trois semaines j'ai trouvé un
livre d'un romancier japonais policier à
policier japonais créé beaucoup aimer un
livre que maurice a pu emprunter
gratuitement le lecteur pourra le
restituer quand il aura terminé ce
dispositif test a été lancée fin janvier
par la région ile de france en
collaboration avec les bibliothèques
locales quinze gares franciliennes dont
trois dans les yvelines participent à
cette expérimentation
l'idée c'est encore une fois de rendre
la culture où tout particulièrement la
lecture accessible à tous les publics et
on s'est dit il faut inventer une
nouvelle forme d'accès à de la lecture
notamment à des nouveaux publics
et pourquoi pas dans les lieux de
fréquentation important des franciliens
et donc les gars est donc plutôt d'être
rivé sur son smartphone pourquoi pas
dans le train pouvoir se pencher sur un
livre découvrir la nouvelle hauteur un
dispositif accueilli avec enthousiasme
par les 65 mille voyageurs quotidiens de
la gare quand on doit attendre un trac
est en retard par exemple ce genre de
choses ça peut être une façon d'attendre
quoi ça peut être sympa surtout que les
fonds passent du temps dans les
transports donc ça peut être sympa si on
y trouve son compte en lecture dans six
mois un premier bilan sera tiré sur
cette expérimentation si cette dernière
est concluante 200 gares franciliennes
pourraient être équipés de boîtes à
livres d'ici 2020